[Music]
welcome back so we're using the singular
value decomposition to compute the eigen
faces so I have a large library of
pictures of human faces arranged as
column vectors of this big matrix X and
we're using the SVD to get eigenfaces to
decompose this library of human faces
into a set of kind of orthogonal eigen
faces that somehow capture the relevant
features in a lower dimensional in a
lower dimensional way okay so we've just
computed this we've loaded this data
matrix X from the Yale data Yale faces
database we've computed its SVD the left
singular vectors these column vectors of
the matrix u can be they have the same
height the same the same size as one of
my reshaped faces the column vector of X
and so I can take those left singular
vectors and reshape them into these
eigen faces so that's what we did now
what I'm going to show you is how I can
use these eigen faces to approximate a
human face that was a new human face so
I built this library on the first 36
people now I'm gonna take images of the
37th person that I did not use to train
this decomposition and I'm gonna see how
well these eigen face this eigen space
this eigen face space represents that
37th person okay so I'm gonna take that
person's face and it's going to be a
column vector X ok it's gonna be a tall
skinny vector that's been essentially
reshaped to be a 32,000 dimensional
vector and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna project it into my eigen face
space I'm gonna take the first are
columns of U my first are eigen faces
and the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna project X into that eigen face
space so literally what I do is I take
my tall skinny matrix X and I multiply
it by my basis of eigenfaces you are
transposed so I take u R and I knock it
on its side and I multiply it by X and
what I get out are essentially the
coefficients or the fingerprint of that
person X is faced in that court
system so it's the mixture of those are
eigenfaces I would have to add up to get
that person's face so projecting X into
the eigen face space I go from a big
tall n-dimensional measurement down to
our numbers that tell me the mixture of
those are eigen faces I would have to
add up to reconstruct X and then if I
want to reconstruct an approximation of
X in that space I would just multiply it
again I would take that linear
combination of eigen faces so let me
just walk through this again if I just
took x times u R transpose I would get
this vector I sometimes call it alpha
it's a little R dimensional vector of
exactly the mixture of eigenfaces the
first our eigenfaces that X has and then
if I took that mixture and I mixed up
those eigenfaces I took that linear
combination of U R I would reconstruct
an approximation of X using that rank R
approximation ok so this would be let's
call this X approximate X tilde okay
this is equal to something that has the
same size as X but it's the projection
of X onto the first R eigenfaces
ok and that's what we're gonna do here
what we're gonna do and I want to show
you how this person's face gets
reconstructed if I keep the first 25 50
hundred eigenfaces the first 200 400 800
and so on so for different rank
different numbers of eigenfaces I'm
going to use to approximate this
person's face we're gonna see how
accurate that reconstruction is and
we're going to compute the reconstructed
face again I'm gonna I subtract it out
the average face so I have to add back
the average face and then I'm gonna take
this projection of my test face into the
first R eigenspaces times the first R
eigenfaces and I'm gonna plot this and
you're gonna see what it looks like and
we can we can work through it okay so
this is my image of person 37 good
this is person 37 right here and then
these are the approximations of
increasing rank 25 50 100 200 if I keep
more and more eigenfaces if I if my my
alpha vector gets larger and larger
containing more information about these
eigenfaces
you can see that pretty quickly his face
does in fact converge to the true face
now it's important to point out that we
did not use this individuals images to
train in the training data X to Train
these libraries these were trained on
the first 36 people this is the 37th
person at rank 25 it doesn't look
anything like him it just looks again
like that kind of generic average face
blobby face and as you start increasing
I would say around 200 is where you
start seeing some semblance of those the
same kind of facial features and
structure of this person and by 400 or
800 I think you'd be able to pick out
this person in a lineup you'd be able to
tell that that really is this person
okay so remember the original image had
about 32,000 pixels that was a lot of
information and now in this eigen face
space we only need the first 400 bits of
information we only need this this 400
tall alpha vector that tells kind of the
the unique fingerprint of this face in
that library now of course if I wanted
to use this for compression or for
encoding or analysis I'd have to store
that library we'd all have to have a
copy of it if we wanted to use this to
decode that person's face in terms of
this compressed representation but if we
all agreed on that library we could do a
much much better job of compressing the
information down from you know 32,000
pixels down to a few hundred
coefficients in this alpha vector so I
think this is kind of a fun example of
what you can do with the eigenfaces you
can use it to show that the structure of
human faces is inherently low
dimensional okay
out of those 32,000 possible pixels that
could make up a face you know people's
faces all have very similar patterns
we're not just random you know you can't
just randomly assign those 32,000 pixels
there's structure we have eyes
noses and mouths and things like that
okay and so those patterns is why you
can get away with this massive
compression of information but when I
was building this example I started
thinking it would be fun to see how this
orthogonal space of eigenfaces could be
used to approximate a different image
that was not even a person's face so
remember the columns of U are
orthonormal and if I kept enough of them
I would actually span a high dimensional
vector space right I'd span a 2400
dimensional subspace of image space
using these orthogonal orthogonal basis
vectors or eigenfaces so now what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
picture of my dog mort and we're gonna
see if we can represent Mort in our eye
in face space so exactly the same issue
a dog let's call it Mort yeah it's this
is a smaller cropped square version of
my dog it's called Mort and I think this
is just fascinating so all that we've
changed we're still using the eigen
faces to represent our images but the
only thing that's changed here is now
instead of trying to reconstruct a human
face I'm trying to reconstruct a picture
of my dog Mort okay and so you can see
at 25 rank and 50 rank and a hundred
rank it just looks like a weird person
right it doesn't look like a person or a
dog exactly but it's more like a person
but then something interesting happens
there's kind of this phase change as you
increase the rank more and more remember
those singular values were decaying
pretty slowly and at some point as you
increase the rank of the approximation
that the Subspace more and more and more
you start to see that a dog emerges now
it's not a perfect representation of my
dog because this is only spanning 2,400
kind of dimensions of this 32,000
dimensional image space but it's pretty
remarkable at 1600 modes kept that's
clearly a picture of a dog not just a
dog my dog okay that's Mort and so it's
really remarkable that this this eigen
face space because it's orthogonal
it actually captures a lot of features
that you can use to reconstruct other
things which is I mean I'm not
recommending you ever do this it's just
interesting that you can do this and you
can also do this even not even a picture
of an animal you can do this with a
picture of a coffee cup okay you can
reconstruct this is some latte art that
Nathan cuts made this beautiful
cappuccino here and you can see again as
you increase the rank of the
approximation the space that you're
using to express this image as you
include more and more and more modes I
mean it's not a perfect representation
there's issues you don't see the like
the pattern in the in the foam but you
can tell that it's a coffee cup with a
spoon on a plate okay so very
interesting you can use this eigen face
space to represent your data and to
essentially represent at least human
faces using a much much less information
namely what mixture of those eigen faces
for that particular person okay so next
we're going to use this for image
classification which is a really
powerful use of eigenfaces okay thank
you